And now to keep us in our oopsie
mood. Here's another Cupertino oops.
From language expert Ben Zimmer.
So back in October, oh six Reuters,
the news wire had an article
about honeybees. And uh,
there was some very interesting sentences
in this article about honey bees,
for instance.
Did you know quote Queen Elizabeth has
10 times the lifespan of workers and lays
up to 2000 eggs a day. That's
why she's a very nice girl,
but doesn't have a lot to say because
there's all these eggs dropping on the
floor with its highly evolved social
structure of tens of thousands of worker
bees commanded by Queen Elizabeth.
The honeybee genome could also improve
the search for genes linked to social
behavior. So every time a
clean reference came in,
they were commanded to that
particular queen. Whenever the words,
the Queen appeared in this
article, it had to be the queen.
So the queen was being
replaced with Queen Elizabeth,
unfortunately in an
article about honeybees.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
this next oop singular oop, wouldn't
it be, I mean, if you have one, oop.
Wouldn't be never heard that man sister
a new clinic. Oop. This next one.
It raises the question of, I
guess you'd say, of moral balance.
The question that I don't think any of
us would want to have to answer comes to
us from our producer, Lulu Miller.
Okay, so set up this story a,
this story happens where it's in a little
town in northern Michigan called Myo
7:00 AM just drove through
the Delaware water gap.
That's me on my way out
there from New York.
The Sun is rising and it's about an 800
mile drive and it's just gorgeous out
here. Listen to you. Lush and nausea.
I know, but I'm just one of those
people. When I get out into nature,
I feel my in the world
anyways. Crossed into Myo.
What was the reason you were
going again to see a bird? A very,
not just rare,
not just the kind of bird birders
get obsessed about this is a bird.
This is what they call a life bird
life. Birders wait their life to see it.
Really? Yeah. Only found right
here. What's the bird called?
The Kirtland warbler. And have you,
have you seen apparently before? No,
I've never seen one. This is my first
trip up here and this right here.
Where are you?
We're just outside of town on the edge
of the forest about to go in and I'm
standing with about 15 people
who come from everywhere.
Are you folks coming from to see this?
Bert, Toledo. I'm from South Carolina.
We're from Oregon, Wyoming.
We'll walk out to a spot,
try to stay single file park ranger leads
us down a path into a little clearing
and pretty immediately back
ground there. Way Back there.
The guy from Ohio,
spots of Kirtland there.
See good turn around the tiny
yellow bird back there, right there.
Up High in the Jack Pine Tree. Oh
Great. It's singing like crazy.
The lady from Dayton starts clapping.
Grab what you're saying. I see
a lovely bird with a gray bag.
This is a guy from Oregon, Jim Coleman,
blue gray bag and his wife Frieda smaller
than a rob and brilliant yellow in the
sunlight is just an
absolutely radiant bird. Yeah.
Is this worth the trip tomorrow
again? Oh, you bet. I don't know.
It just makes me thankful
that I'm here. So,
and it makes me grateful
that my wife is here.
I know this is something she's
willing to see a lot for a long time.
I know Jim actually starts to tear up.
It's a very special bird.
Oh my hand. Yeah, that guy.
And that's what this story is really
about. How special is this bird?
Meaning well, how much
is a species? Right,
right.
Um, well, here's the backstory. Okay.
In the early seventies the
warbler almost went extinct.
The reason why it was thought was
because of a little creature called the
Calbert. I want to go in. Okay.
That's just the sound of them.
It's a parasite, you know,
on someone who is this guy?
This is Chris Mensing fish and wildlife
biologist with the US fish and wildlife
service.
And we're standing in this cage full
of cowbirds or looks like we've got six
males and one female.
Let me grab a couple.
You just reached out and grabbed two of
them. You can put it that and the males.
Yeah, go ahead.
Imagine a tiny little gnarly crow
got really sharp little beaks,
but with this blunt dagger like beats,
very drab body. I'm very doll to,
here's what the Calbert does to the
warbler while the warbler is out of its
nest, like getting a
worm or something. Yeah.
The Calbert lay is one of its own
eggs in the nest to make room for it.
So the warbler doesn't
know anything is up.
It pushes out one of the warblers
eggs. Oh yeah. To the nest.
And the timing is such that the cupboard
egg will hatch first and will double
its size in 24 hours. Wow. So by
the time that the host birds hatch,
that Coburg may be up to four times the
size and when they start begging for
food, but parents, the loudest,
most aggressive chick is going
to get fed the cupboard chick.
So the warbler mom ends up shoveling
food into this Calbert chip. Yep.
Oftentimes it gets so much food
that another warbird chick will die.
So when the cowbirds first showed up in
this area in late 18 hundreds early 19
hundreds the warbler population
just started plummeting.
This huge drop by 1971 are
only 200 males on earth.
Well, so what do you do? Are
you asking me [inaudible]
um, I guess you get to
kill the cat. Exactly. Um,
this is one of 54 traps and new
one that we just built this year,
which is why we're out in this cage. It's
actually a cowbird trap. Oh, she did?
Yeah, she, yeah, she bite me. They just
like anyone else, get someone larger,
grabbing you. They don't
appreciate it too much.
And so anyone know how to
kill him? I kind of do. Yeah.
Thoracic compression is the term we
use. We basically squeeze the bird,
suffocating and preventing it from
breathing in your hands. There's no, Yup.
Yup. Yeah. You have to do that. Yeah.
Like all the time. Yeah. Did you see this?
No,
but 1972 fish and wildlife service
sets up a bunch of traps a few years,
and about 12,000 dead cow birds later
[inaudible]
kind of the population stopped dying off,
but then it didn't start
bouncing back. What's going on?
Why aren't we seeing bigger numbers now
that we're catching the copperheads,
that's Rita Harbison.
She worked with the forest service back
in the 80s and we thought well if we
finally concluded it must be
just, there is not enough habitat.
Like they don't have enough trees.
Well No, there are plenty of trees.
But the thing about warblers is
they like a specific kind of tree.
They like them very young.
They're like I'm young, but they like
young trees is what you're saying. Yup.
And there aren't young trees in
this place? No. It's really weird.
When when they started looking
around this forest they noticed,
well the trees were really, really old.
Why wouldn't there be young trees? Well
[inaudible] hey smokey bear seat.
When humans began to settle in this
area of Michigan in about the 1880s they
brought with them that certain
human disdain for fire.
The fire is exactly what's needed
up there to make new trees.
This ecosystem is a fire
ecosystem says Chris, it burns.
Cause when these trees burn,
they release their seeds and
make room for new trees to grow.
It is a fire ecosystem. It is
made to burn. So I ask you again,
what do you do? Do you start
fires? Would that be the solution?
That would be the solution. While,
so the forestry started doing,
when we call a prescribed
burn, basically it says Rita,
they burned down a little patch of forest,
a few acres to regenerate it and one
windy spring day in 1980 at a place called
Mac Lake. The forestry service started a
fire that they probably shouldn't have.
Okay. My name is Dick Lord. At
the time of the Mac lake fire,
I was part of the ignition
crew for the prescribed burn.
What does an ignition crew,
uh, they liked the farm.
So at 10 in the morning,
Dick and his crew go out into the
woods when the plants start setting up
perimeters and they begin lighting a few
stands of shrubs. I was driving home,
that's Bob Burner. Best
name ever for firefighter.
I could see for service
starting to do a burn.
And I thought this is not
a good time. It was windy.
They didn't have the man
power. And I says, well,
it probably would be getting
called out here shortly.
Basically we did not realize that whether
it was going to change as rapidly as
it did, the wind came up suddenly,
something nobody could predict and it
took the fire across the road into a
standard mature Jack Pine.
[inaudible] flames, probably
a hundred 150 feet in here.
The sound is like a roaring train before
his guys jumped into their bulldozers,
trying to plow trenches alongside the
pinch at all and I mean you can feel the
heat. It was way out of our control
hitting the tops of the trees rolling.
I knew at the rate it was traveling
that no one was going to be a major
catastrophe
within six hours. It had
burned over 20,000 acres.
It's one of the fastest moving fires
ever documented. Yeah. Well through here,
far as you can see, it was all
black. These are two guys I,
Bob owned houses in the
area that got burnt.
I remember the guy down there in a corner.
Yeah, grabbed it off during the drop.
The Black Charlie, their houses were okay,
but 41 houses were destroyed all the
way up to the lake, so just completely,
yeah, nothing green. No like
something out of a moonscape fire.
As you could see,
everything gone and the worst part about
it for all of us that's read a hell of
a sin. Again, one set, it killed.
One of the forest service employees,
a very young wildlife technician who
was very well loved by his coworkers.
A guy named Jim Swiderski and
old Jim was a good friend.
Yeah.
As well as an employee
declared again, Jim's boss.
He told me that Jim had been
a postman for a few years,
but just loved birds so much that he
took a huge pay cut to come and help
protect the warbler. Basically
what happened was, oh,
the fire overran him. Oh,
the press was having a heyday just tearing
into the forest service for what had
happened. The towns, people were
very angry at the forest service.
How can you do this? Rita says,
they were told not to wear their
forest service uniforms in town. Gosh,
it was so terrible in the
forest itself. You know,
there was nothing there.
It was completely silent.
But a year later,
a little bit of green started to poke up
in the next year a little bit more and
eight to 10 years after that Mac like
Bern just seemed like everywhere you
turned around you'd stop for, listen,
there were five or six birds,
the tremendous number of person.
That was the, the answer to the
mystery, the fire. You know,
if you look at a population graph,
that's Christmas sing again.
After that medical lake population
went like that, he points his hands
straight up. And so it's pretty dramatic.
Today the numbers are
up to almost 4,000 birds
and growing, seeing it like crazy
now that the birds are
back, but a man has gone.
When you walk around this town,
a question lingers in the air.
Weiss was a fireman
worth the life of a bird?
Pick a woman.
No. My opinion it isn't.
This is Ed Faucet.
I wouldn't trade your life for a bird
and sitting with him and his wife,
Mary Jane and then in a diner.
And no matter where you go in
this town, government doing,
people don't tend to be huge fans of
the warbler. It's just a small bird.
And I've been up here since 68 I'd never
seen one. Did you ever see one? No,
never have I seen it. And back
to Ed, I just got to say to you,
what would you think about it?
If your father or brother
were killed for a bird,
be pretty hard to accept, wouldn't it?
But if you zoom out one human
life versus the end of a species,
you know how many workers
there are in the United States?
Cause something like 37 species of
warblers and the real number is actually
closer to 60 that's kind of ridiculous.
And that's not all the asco. When are
you done? And we really say never.
Chris explained to me that they have to
keep killing the cowbirds and they have
to keep doing burns, smeller burns.
But every single year if we let things
be, the bird would be extinct. Wow.
That's the hard thing about this job
is knowing that we're never done.
How many people are working,
how much you're probably looking
at hundreds of people. Well,
over $1 million a year spent. All
of this began to really sink in.
I'm one of my last mornings
out there. All right.
It is five in the morning. It was
the annual Kirtland warbler. Census
were birders from all over the world
show up to help count how many warblers
there are out there. Is it like there
is a warbler step that steps up?
There's a warbler. Yeah. Yeah.
That's actually exactly how it works.
I was paired up with
this guy, Dave Mendez.
We're going to kind of walk through
the middle of these transects.
We're going to come up. He's kind
of a dude, dude. He's an older guy,
got a beard and work for
an electrical contractor.
Told me he's got a man room and man
room. You know, most guys got sports,
but I've got Kirtland's warbler
pictures up on the wall,
so I went into it thinking like, this'll
be really cool. We'll march along.
We'll count it. I looked at the
map. It was a mile maybe of a walk.
We'll be done in 20 minutes.
Well, okay, maybe not.
We're rocking through the forest on our
top and we set off dense brambly forest.
Still Dark, so that was a hermit.
Thrush. Okay. Let me just play
you a quick little time lapse.
20 to seven right now the sun's just
coming up and it's get a little muggy out
here.
Yeah, it was a curtain. Oh yeah.
Yeah. We can't count them though.
He's not in our section seven oh
seven I heard one way back that way.
Yeah. Yeah. There it is again,
but I'm not going to mark
them then because I don't
know exactly where he's at.
Seven 33 there he go.
Yeah. Nope. Right there.
No, no, no,
no, nope. We want to be a lot more
accurate. We want to triangulate them.
Nine 56 in all's well
in the warbler woods.
A couple of anther biting me. Yeah, they
hurt down there. They do a little bit.
Yeah.
Get Out of there 10:45 AM I
know that there's a bird out
[inaudible] I can still hear
that burden lay back there.
So we ended up staying out there
for seven and a half hours.
Just marked one, right?
Yup. Only mark one.
And I don't mean to sound
like I'm making fun of Dave.
I mean he's doing his job well,
but at some point in between the fire
ants and taking four hours to confirm this
one bird, he's going to be right off.
I just started thinking
about all the effort.
It takes Rosa trees over from us and I
can't see them. I just suddenly thought
it's this Fussy, fragile little bird
and it hasn't evolved. Who Cares?
Yeah. I mean this is not worth it.
And so I started asking
people who protect the bird,
why do that with so much
money? And it's all for a bird.
And I could see it maybe
if it was for some,
but it's just one warbler of 18 million
different kinds of warblers. Like,
why do it? Well, we do it
cause we should, you know,
we're stewards of the land. That's
Chris Mensing again. Cowbird killer.
It's for future generations and well,
here's the firestarter Dick Lord.
You know the Kirtland's warbler was listed
under the endangered species act and
we had a charge under the law to do
what we could to recover its existence.
And that's the only thing that
I can say that all we had to do,
what the law required us to do.
So we should do it and the
law tells us we have to do it.
Unconvincing and that question is a little
wife of a farm on worth the life of a
bird and that guy at at the diner,
it just stuck in my mind and I realized
I couldn't leave this town until I
talked to the people who lost the most.
I just skated and introduced yourselves.
Yeah, sure. Robert Sweaters,
ski age 54 Kathleen Sweater Ski,
Florence [inaudible] Ski, the mother,
mother and the mother. The guy died. Yeah,
I that's it.
What? Iced tea or water even. We're
all sitting around the kitchen table,
dogs and beer over there. Jim's
brother-in-law's there. Twos off. Kevin,
Kevin Debris and I asked them to tell
me about Jim. Quite a guy. Soft spoken.
Smart. Quite a character. Yeah.
They told me at first they were furious.
They should have never ever sent him
in there. Angry at the forest service.
Angry about this bird.
No. Very angry. Now,
three decades later, I say you keep that
a little bird calling. Exactly. Really?
Jim's younger brother Robert said that
the thing he wanted the most is for the
Kirtland's warbler to become the state
bird by that. That would be the ultimate,
Huh?
That would be the biggest accomplishment
ever would be that be in a state bird.
Wow. I guess I'm, I'm,
I guess in some ways I'm surprised
like I didn't mean to come here with
expectations,
but in some ways I thought if it was
my family that I would hate that bird.
I would just hate that
bird. No, it's not the bird.
I mean that bird didn't do anything
to any of us. Right. You know,
if we can keep it going, I mean
that's what he set out to do.
Let's keep it going. They
think about Jim's death.
Any of the military guys
like the death of a soldier,
where would you be setting right now?
We would have lost all those soldiers
in world war a war, World War II.
He died protecting, you
know, it's only one species.
Well then this could be another species
and another species in another species.
Next thing you know, you walk out
in the morning and it'll be quiet.
Thank God for the Teddy Roosevelt and
the boys that made our national parks.
Imagine what if we didn't have those? It
costs money. It's painful, blah, blah,
blah. You gotta have the guts to do that.
And Jim was really that kind of
guy. Now that is convincing. Yeah,
but I mean, do you agree
for us? And I asked the mom,
what can I say? The
bird could come in back,
but the life was gone.
So why bring it up again? It's done. It's,
you can't bring it back. So
you have to live by that.
But there's always a hole in your heart,
something that none of us
will ever forget forever.
Don't ask me any more questions, please.
Okay.
And then, Oh, good.
Oh, the power went out.
Give me a break. Oh. Oh,
cool. We go home and get the generator.
Where do you go
Lulu? Miller.